hey youtubers it's Charlie so I cobbled
together this spider-man homecoming
interview that Tom Holland and zendaya
did I know he's dancing here and that
reminds me of Tobey Maguire dancing in
spider-man 3 Tom Hollands actually a
pretty good dancer they just talked a
little bit about coming together being
new Marvel royalty in this universe like
now they're teenagers and Tom Holland is
getting ready to be an a-list Avenger so
big big deal and they just confirmed
that he signed on for the two more
spider-man movies meaning they've
confirmed that Sony and Marvel will be
making a full spider-man homecoming
trilogy so I'll talk about those other
two movies at the end of this so enjoy
[Music]
best thing about being spider-man that's
such a tough question
um I think so far the best thing about
it is is visiting the Children's
Hospital right I'm actually not oh but
not about me being spider-man best thing
about being spider-man I'm not actually
spider-man by the way I just pretend top
of the Empire State Building by King
Kong spider-man well I mean I'm not
really an Avenger so probably ant-man I
think I just I love Paul Rudd he's such
a great guy we were in a in Berlin the
other day working and he just showed up
in my green room he just walked in and
came and hung out with me for an hour
and he's just such a nice guy and also
he's so funny in that movie that I think
he is definitely my favorite event
how to put a pocket square into the soup
yeah add a bit of a disaster last night
I ended up giving up and just stuffing
it in a club Idon't like a rave that
would be the worst thing ever me just be
terrible ha ha my first meetings and
there was very embarrassing actually for
me I don't remember this but he says
that there was some type of awkward hug
shake thing was just one of those
moments where I just wasn't my smoothest
it's mu this moment it was kind of like
a oh hey woo you know was one of those
[Music]
he's so nice he's like one of the nicest
people I think I've ever met he's just a
good dude and so that it's really good
to see that good things going on for
like a good person I didn't really know
what to expect resent there and I was
excited to see what she was like and I
was so surprised and so happy she's one
of the most professional hard-working
people I've ever met in my life
we were at the screen tests for
spider-man homecoming and we did the
first scene together and I think the
producers cast stuff like then before
she even left the room they knew that
she was going to play her character
my character Michelle is very awkward
and dry and kind of weird a little bit
which is funny because I feel like she
is how I feel inside she's very smart
intelligent I think she feels like she's
a little bit above everybody mentally
and so she just kind of watches
everybody observes it's kind of quiet to
herself reading all the time it's pretty
[Music]
who's my favorite superhero now it would
sound corny if I said spider-man right
but he is smart and I'm not saying that
now because I am spider-man it's been
spider-man since I was a little kid he's
a humble kid you know and he had kind of
like a little bit of a rough background
and he's a nerd and he gets picked on
and you know as you grow up you find
what your purpose is you find what
you're good at you find what makes you
feel powerful and so that's what he has
to do my best friend Harrison his
favorite is Batman and for years we've
had an argument on who would win in the
fight spider-man or Batman I win every
argument now about you know how I know
cuz I am spider-man so shut your face
tell us about the video of you and Tom
doing choreograph routine oh well my
friend our boyfriend Connie came up with
this dance challenge and she was like
hey you know would you do with me she's
like my best friend you know and I'm
like yeah of course and we were chilling
at Tom's house and we're like oh Tom do
you want to do it he was like yeah for
sure he's a dancer like I don't know if
anybody's ever seen him but like he can
freakin spin like no other we just sort
of had a little taunting session it was
really fun really fun day so before I
talk about the other two spider-man
sequels something really interesting
happened in that interview in case you
missed it zendaya referred to herself as
Michelle is in Michelle Gonzalez the
spider-man character who was a love
interest for him for a certain period in
the comics I know there was all that
news about her secretly being Mary Jane
and then just using the Michelle name as
a misdirect that might be what's going
on here because when they were doing
this interview they chyron her and they
just say actress
spider-man homecoming they didn't say
her character named spider-man
homecoming because I've heard it a
couple different ways but at the end of
this I'll link to the comic-con cast
interview where the director calls her
out as Michelle again so they just keep
calling her Michelle and all the
interviews she has this quote where she
talks about her character not being a
love interest in the movie but she
doesn't flat-out say I'm not Mary Jane
but she pretty much says that so I'm
glad to believe her but her quote is my
character is not romantic she's like a
very dry awkward intellectual and
because she's so smart she just feels
like she doesn't need to talk to people
like my brain is so far ahead of you
you're not really on my level so she
comes off really
weird but then zendaya addressing her
own character says but to me she is very
cool because she's deep she's always
thinking about something always reading
so that does not sound like any version
of mary-jane that's happened so far even
the version of mary-jane that is now or
has been Tony Stark's assistant in the
most recent Marvel Comics so I am
inclined to believe her that she is not
playing the mary jane love interest in
the movie so you guys can let me know
what you think do you think that she's
basically confirming that she is not
Mary Jane in the movie and she's
actually going to be the Michelle
Gonzales character which I think would
also be a really interesting character
it sounds like they have an interesting
spin on it but I think the people would
be less inclined to start a riot over
her playing Michelle Gonzales but just
to talk about the two Spider Man
homecoming sequels I think we all kind
of assumed that they would be doing a
new spider-man trilogy but this just
confirms it Tom Holland will be
spider-man they'll follow him through
high school Harry Potter style that's
actually the thing that Kevin Feige
referenced when he was talking about
this version of Peter Parker like we've
seen billionaire industrialist playboy
you know Iron Man now we're gonna see
something like that from a kid's
perspective and that's going to be
filled by this version of spider-man so
it's not like we're gonna see him in
high school for one year and then he's
going to be like in his mid-20s for the
next two films we're gonna see him in
his sophomore year in spider-man
homecoming next summer that's when the
film is dropping next summer so we know
there's a lot of question about how he
can only go through one year of school
when like a couple years have gone by in
the Marvel Universe normally the Marvel
films move in real time but I think
that's slowly going to stop is they
release more in more movies each year
they'll be a little more flexible with
their timeline but thanks to Kevin Feige
they will not have the x-men caught nua
t problem where none of it makes sense
when you all look at at the end of the
day so even though it sounds weird that
we're going to get like a spider-man
movie every two years but he's only
going to age one year at a time don't
worry about it they'll totally explain
how it's going to work when they start
doing more press for the movie and I
know we're getting ready for a teaser to
drop they haven't confirmed when that's
going to happen but a lot of people seem
to think that it's going to be in early
December no worries if there is
something that drops I will totally do a
video for it but as of right
now I haven't heard anything official
about a trailer dropping anytime soon
so the leading candidate unless they
just drop a surprise trailer would be
the Super Bowl next year which is during
February so because I'll be doing
spider-man bonus videos for the rest of
the year
some of them will focus on those sequels
like the storylines that I think they
should do the villains they should use
obviously I think that Norman Osborn
should have a presence somewhere in here
even though the vulture is going to be
the villain of the first big movie I
think we'll see all the classic
spider-man stuff manifest eventually but
I don't think they want to do something
that's already been done so many times
like they did Green Goblin
during Tobey Maguire era then they did
them again during Andrew Garfield era so
I don't think they want to just keep
recycling the same spider-man characters
but yet I be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a new Legend episode
tonight they're forming the Legion of
Doom officially reverse-flash Miami Vice
Legion of Doom it's going to be so much
fun I'll post that video after it airs
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that other spider-man
interview with the director talks about
the cast and you can click here to learn
all about Young Justice season 3 thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you